all right crash
crash show where where'd you grow up
where are you from originally i was born
in spokane washington uh in 1980
about 14 days before mount st helens
blew up was that right yeah
tell me about your family growing up
yeah mom and dad uh no i i was in you
know estate placement like from a really
early age my mom lost custody of me when
i
was
about two and a half three years old um
i don't really remember the details up
to that point but i've been told that um
she ran around with a lot of
nerdy wells and heathens you know what i
mean like we all do um
like a circle of black and white not red
and white but black and white like the
gypsy jokers and uh she was pretty busy
with that and um bikers yeah like
kicking with them being a little house
fraud and all that
but uh she ran into somebody that like
had other ideas for what they wanted to
do and he took her on a ride like
robin banks robbing stores
and that was the last time i seen my mom
until i was like 19 years old
i grew up state placement in
washington in oregon
you know about
30 plus
placements over the course of my my
young life until i started running away
at like 11 12 years old and then by the
time i was 15 i'd ran away so much that
they just
stopped chasing me so you you basically
had no parents ever no
no real family ties
i mean yeah there's family around for a
while but they're all gone now except
for my kids
and then
the last the last of the mohicans i
guess
how far did you want school uh i
actually got my uh
equivalency and uh uh in 1998 with the
same year i would have graduated i got
into county jail
um
so yay class of 98.
you so you went to prison early
i went to prison when i was 20
almost 21 years old
um
i was 21 actually and uh
[Music]
i didn't get until i was like 40.
what was that for uh second-degree
attempt murder but it's it's funny
because
someone died and they blamed me for
something else it was
the weirdest thing and
it's messed up too because the details
of this are kind of like
they caused me some
severe
harm you know i mean like it's not like
i did something wrong i did something
wrong but i didn't do
okay so
i had twins
and
um
one of them died
since and she will when we woke up she
had like
vomit on her mouth i picked her up and i
turned her over and it came out and came
out of her mouth now i remember that and
for years they
were at me about
these injuries and smore [ __ ] and like i
was like what i would remember this i
remember
doing some crazy stuff like this i would
i'm cognizant of everything i've ever
done i've
almost a near identic memory
for any anything
even and especially my own family
when she passed
a couple days went by and they arrested
both me and her mom
and
after the first arraignment they
separated our case
and so that means she was already trying
to tell on me like trying to blame it on
me what's interesting about this and
what never came to light in court
um was that she had had other children
before i got with her
that had been
termed fas or like something wrong with
them like mentally like developmentally
disabled or they were
not healthy children like they had other
injuries and they put it on me because i
got like a violent past and some more
[ __ ] so
it's interesting the way this shook out
because
i took the wrap to get her out
because i was like well [ __ ] if
somebody's gonna sink for it it's gonna
be me so i might as well just rock that
and as [ __ ] up as that was i felt like
i was doing the right thing
until years later
someone from my past
who had been
trying to go to school to be a social
worker and help kids
had access to my file and read the whole
thing all the paperwork for court and
then came across other information that
disputed
what had been what i've been playing for
and was later like partially exonerated
but at the same time like not completely
granted because they can't just undo
19 years of incarceration they don't
need a lot of money you know what i mean
for you know false imprisonment but
what's [ __ ] up about it is it still
doesn't bring
it doesn't bring her back
and
every time i leave to go somewhere
i got to be on [ __ ] like
super swivel high alert like i'm i'm on
complete
personal security around people and me
and myself and the people that i'm with
because there's people that know that
love me that know what happened
and there's people that
love me anyway but there's a
overwhelming majority of people that
[ __ ] want to see me dead you know i
mean for whatever reason they they think
it's this they think it's this i've
heard 50 different [ __ ] stories about
what i supposedly did
and none of them are [ __ ] true none
of them have any fact to them at all
except for
the one thing
that she's gone
and
i have to suffer that every [ __ ]
moment of my life in my own self
and then everybody else's dispersions
too
that's too much
so
now i just i rock high alert like i got
weapons on me at all times i'm not gonna
get
like ran up on and just not be able to
defend myself i'm gonna [ __ ] hurt
somebody too
because they're not just gonna take me
they're gonna take my wrath too and i'm
not selling my life cheap because i
still got two other kids
you know what i mean i'm here for them
otherwise i would have just shuffled off
you
know there's a lot there's a lot more
where are your kids
where are your kids um
they're both with family um on their on
their mom's side because i i don't have
any family anymore but
um my kids love
love their dad especially julianne
athena
i mean that's disputable but
deanna
swore that that was mine and then took
it back and then it's a mess because we
don't get along anymore but
i love my kids man
and and i love
all people i try to love everybody you
know what i mean it's just
they make it real difficult to be a good
person
you know
just tired of getting kicked
how long you been in
uh i've been in la for uh [ __ ]
i started here when i came down here my
mom lived in london
so i i was in the south bay
um
that was
about 24
three years ago something like that and
i did my 19 years and then i've been out
for two and a half
so
all in all i've been in california
probably more than anywhere else in my
life
i'm 41 about 32.
and drugs are part of your life
drugs
yeah i mean as much as i hate to admit
it it's the only way that i can numb
myself enough to like
not go
and lock myself in my room and just
puking my own mouth
about
how much people bothered me you know
like
i was never the type to be so outspoken
to say like
you're pissing me off or like i feel
like you're a piece of [ __ ] or
if if if it came to me saying something
it was long overdue because i'll
i'll be humble and i'll be you know
generous and be friendly until like it's
glaringly obvious that i'm being
disrespected or took advantage of and
then i start getting i i plex on it i
start getting
bad feelings about it i start feeling
like
they're reaching for something or
they're trying to work me out or
something and i pledge and
generally
when i was younger that would cause a
situation where somebody get hurt
either me or the other person's or a
person
um
so i've always been quick to fill my
hand i'm a small guy you know i don't i
don't i don't got much weight in my ass
so i like i gotta feel my hand
um
i don't know man for better or worse
sometimes i don't even know what i'm
hanging on to
you're living on the streets now
yeah um i'm actually trying to
have to santa cruz i got a job up there
and
my homeboy is up there like it's like a
brother to me but
even that we got we got scars too you
know
so like i want to go up there and work
um
for like few months and then save us
some money and probably bounce to
argentina or something
just
change the whole situation up some
fluent in spanish too
just
it made my home feel like it wasn't a
home anymore
how do you support yourself now
um generally like
i got i got hustle i sell drugs i'll buy
a big-ass sack and i'll split this stuff
up and i'm good at micromanaging so i
can i can hustle really well
um
that being said that kind of leaves me
out there a little bit my name's out
there ringing a little bit and i don't
want people to know where i'm at or who
i am
so even on google my account says i'm
nobody from nowhere
you know like i don't even
really have a picture other than in my
own account you know what i mean like
did i see nobody else sees it
give any friends
i gotta i had a couple like close people
to me but
when people get that deep and like your
flick it's really easy for them to stab
you in the back and i've experienced
that too so
i just kind of rock alone
i'm more comfortable when i'm just in an
open place by myself
you know
in what ways do you think your
chaotic childhood
affects you as an adult
i heard a lot of mumbo jumbo when i was
a kid about like because i took
counseling i was counseled and i had to
go to counseling and all that stuff like
the shs was big and for the foster
program in washington state so
i always had counseling and
people i had to talk to but
i heard that i would always have
problems
connecting with people
not
interacting with them or
conversationally engaging them or even
not being charming at times but
to have an actual meaningful
relationship with somebody is difficult
for me because
i keep so much in reserve and i'm so
much stressful that if i told them how i
really felt they wouldn't be around me
you know what i mean or what i suspected
that anybody can do anything at any time
and so that that kind of impairs my
ability to trust too because i have to
leave everything open so like this is
possible
you know
i can't firmly negate something and say
no they won't do that because life's
shown me as soon as i say that
here comes the doulo you know what i
mean like here comes the other shoe
dropping usually on my head yeah we're
being handed from family to family to
family that [ __ ] sucks man that's got to
create that kind of you feel like an
alien in your own skin like
you can't even be yourself because every
time you reset you have to be something
for somebody else that's how you figure
out that like
all these other people don't [ __ ]
matter man you got to be okay with
yourself and that was a struggle too but
constantly going from foster placement
to class placement into group homes to
even a place called morningstar boys
ranch
um
it left a lot to be
desired as far as like i knew what i was
missing out with my family like not
being there because i see people come
and take other kids off visits when i
was a kid i'd be like
that must be nice right like to myself i
think like [ __ ] man
i wish someone could pick me up and
[ __ ] take me out for thanksgiving
dinner or whatever
but
you know
you age out and they don't give a [ __ ]
like once you're 18 you're on your face
i was on my face by the time i was 15
you know so
just got a hard head man i've always had
to learn
the worst ways
repeatedly
you know what i mean why not to do
something
do you have any good memories of your
childhood
you know maybe like a first kiss with a
girl or something when i was a little
kid or
i don't know like i liked i liked the
animals a lot i still do
so any time i was like animals around
the dogs that i had and that was cool
people were like
they'd be cool at first
and then like
i guess i'm odd or something man because
like i don't
know conversation is easy we can talk
about anything and i can joke and be
joking
all that stuff but
when it comes to like real life stuff
i still do the same [ __ ] i still try to
joke or i just climb up
and i process it like a normal normal
human being but like my feelings are so
jagged and weird to me like that i don't
want to feel them like this
it feels like it's like a precursor to
something happening like you let the
feelings out or you start expressing
like hey i appreciate you for this and i
really i really like that you did this
and it affected me in a positive way as
soon as you say that [ __ ] [ __ ] gets
weird or like
then the next shuffle happens the next
reset happens and you go somewhere else
so it's just
like a stream of faces washing mind a
stream of [ __ ]
and you just stop looking
and stop like trying to be anything for
anybody it would just
turn inward
but have you been in love before
have i been in love
yeah
every [ __ ] time but
like there's two there's been two
maybe three that have really taken my
breath away and
you know like
obviously i look like the [ __ ] guy
they want to regret and that's fine
but some of them have been genuine
genuine goddesses in the flesh but i
ended up and i've been
i've been blessed to worship
you know
um
love is elusive
and it seems like
okay
it's very much a curse to be loved
what are you afraid of what do you worry
about
at this point in your life
being misunderstood
or
dying before i have a chance to
completely
give my all to my to my kids that i
still
have
i mean like
we all do things cut corners and we
cheat and we do things to like make
money and
my purpose has always been like
even if i couldn't
be there
i would make something for them
and i managed to do that pretty well
i mean uh
i probe with a little bit of money me
and my ex-wife split up
she stole some money from me she stole
about the equivalent of 20 grand for me
and this is this is money on main on the
back of an orphan like this is me doing
this
so i had about i had a good little chunk
of money when i got out she clipped
about
half of it
the rest
i kind of invested
and i kept like 10 for myself i had edd
and i had the extra little money and i
bought
a badass volkswagen gti i was smashing
that around i got to
play around on tracks with it like you
know
race privileges here and there i got
sponsorship by you know
um
some
some cool companies man that build euros
i'm just gonna put it out there but
um
mile seven was bad and i wrecked it
being stupid doing heroin and [ __ ]
with hookers and coming back too late
um thanksgiving a couple years ago
tender died
and then i got another one it was a
lemon so i've had two
they're great cars but
like i said man this is all [ __ ] that i
did on my own like give my license my
registration my my insurance everything
like i was completely legit on parole
getting pulled over by gang task
canines in my car
and i'm laughing at him like
you guys got nothing like i'm not doing
nothing you guys don't hear me i'm not
doing nothing
where's where's it you got you got guns
in there you got you i know you got
drugs in there dude
i got i got some wheat in there you want
it it's an ashtray i got roaches in
there go grab it no i'm talking about
real drugs where's it at tear the car
apart dude
you know you always strip out just don't
put me in the back of the cop car i'll
strip out the side of the road like i'm
going through a work change in prison
i'll get butt naked squat and cough and
all that [ __ ] just don't put me in that
[ __ ] car
is that panic man you know i mean like
i'm [ __ ] panicking that [ __ ] start
getting claustrophobic all that he said
i can't do that [ __ ] again
how about how big a part do drugs play
in your situation today
probably
a larger role than they should like it's
not absolute but
i get high like all the time
your drug is fentanyl um i i like heroin
but
i mean when it comes to like having to
like kill that anxiety in my in myself
it's like a roaring black hole of
unquenchable [ __ ] chaos it's it takes
a lot of drugs i'll do i'll do whatever
like i'll have a pile of chris like i
got right now and be selling it and just
decide you know what i'm gonna do an
eight ball today
and i'll fix it and do it
you know it might take me a couple a
couple times but i'll do it
um now that said like i'm a functioning
addict i can go to work i can work like
that and get a lot done without
appearing spun i'm high as [ __ ] right
now
and i'm not all over the place you know
just
heroin is like my thing when i'm feeling
like really depressed and i just want to
die
and generally that's what it comes to
i'll get saved by emts
like i have been like four or five times
do you get suicidal a lot every day
but i don't act on it i know it's there
once you ring that bell
you can't unring it
you know
and
what's messed up too on that
i went home for a home pass on christmas
one time i was already in
state placement and
grandparents came and got me they took
me to salem oregon where my uncle vince
had used to live
and uh we had christmas out there and i
woke up christmas morning early because
i wanted to catch santa eating the
cookies i set out for his ass
and asked him some questions about why
he gave me what i wanted
uh
and i i found my uncle like hanging in
the garage
i think it was like
seven years old eight years old
i was i was young
and i think that like
i don't know if the seed was planted
that that was a possibility in my head
at that point but i realized that he'd
done that to himself nobody did that to
him he did that to himself
and i even i asked i asked my grandpa
it was a great man like you i don't even
know if he's really my grandpa
i asked him like why he did that and
all i could say was that
he was in pain
and he wanted it to end
i didn't really understand that
then
yeah
what emotions do you go through now
are you depressed or angry or anxiety or
not anxiety is like always a 10 because
i'm always like alert and hyper vigilant
and watching everything and it wears the
[ __ ] out dude like bad
but
i don't get angry as much as
just like
i get frustrated but i don't allow
that reaction i i don't give people that
reaction or the satisfaction of making
me show the monster
you know
unless like my life's in jeopardy or
someone that i love is in jeopardy then
i let it off the leash
for better or worse and
usually comes out
swimmingly
i go to jail or
i get away with whatever the [ __ ]
happened
but usually it solves the situation
for a time you know or it puts the focus
on me as opposed to someone else
so yeah like there's al it's either
depression
i i fight with that all the time but i
find that the medication that they give
you for that it takes something away
from your spirit like your your
personality and
i'm so much of an introvert i can't
afford
to lose any personality because then
i'll just become like a complete outcast
almost like i am no
but completely outcast completely
awkward
and like with a bad attitude and
depressed and no one is going to [ __ ]
give a [ __ ]
that she's a [ __ ] weirdo man i'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's just nobody [ __ ]
that dude
you know
so like it's already
sorry treacherous i can't make it worse
by
being all doped up on [ __ ] [ __ ] that
changes me like in a fundamental way
that doesn't allow me to have a
personality now drugs just take the
feeling out of me i don't have to feel
anything
unfortunately there's other side effects
with that [ __ ] too just like
pharmaceutical drugs
fentanyl
yes about fentanyl uh
yeah see i i got the dumb
and uh i i would slam that [ __ ] and i
kept dying like i kept getting woke up
and i was just like tired of it like
[ __ ] man
i'd come back and it would be
embarrassing like people standing over
me the [ __ ] mask on my mouth
either get narcan up the nose after the
first time they started doing iv
because i kept bottoming back out
uh i didn't realize that you can't slam
fentanyl i just thought i was like
nobody gave me the memo on that
so i once i figured out that i was
falling off every time i kept at it i
was like i can get away with i can get
out i can get out of this i can [ __ ]
parole
to the stars
but they keep bringing me back even when
i got stabbed like i got stabbed like
eight times
something like the size of a k bar
like four months ago it was actually in
a uh
january that was january 10th this year
i stayed in the hospital for like two
weeks chest tube the whole gym
and
i was just pissed that i wouldn't be
able to get my hands on this dude again
you know i waited 30 minutes
to call the [ __ ] paramedics
i waited 30 minutes for this dude to
[ __ ] leave
from where we had this altercation
and he wouldn't leave
so like
when the ambulance showed up
they came and got me
and uh immediately started working on me
because like my lung was collapsed
because i'd already been waiting too
long
and uh
i guess they arrested him but
i told him i was like hey dude [ __ ]
get on i got something for you when i
see you get [ __ ] get on
you know i mean
because i mean we were fighting for a
minute he swung at me with the blade
i caught it in my hand and i cut another
one in the hand and i kind of went up
the side of the arm and then slashed on
the side and then [ __ ] by the time
that was happening i was on top of him
falling out
and
he stabbed me in the back dude those are
the ones that [ __ ] like damn here
killed me hit the lung nicked my heart
like a heart sack
i think it was on methadone for a while
because that heart sack was swollen a
little bit
gave my heart a little bit of help and
it almost hit my spine too so that could
have been paralyzed
heart shot or [ __ ] just lung done
three ways
and i survived that [ __ ]
and they got my [ __ ] face cut two
months later
i was so [ __ ] mad
like this [ __ ] [ __ ] right here still
got stitches it's not supposed to have
stitches i just never went back to
hospitals
i just don't got the time i was trying
to get everything ready to
talk to my pro officer about hey can i
get a transfer i'm almost on parole i'm
tired of [ __ ] this [ __ ] like every
time i leave the house i gotta worry
about like who's the next pump that's
going to run out who's the next
motherfucker's gonna [ __ ] come at me
with some sideways [ __ ]
you know what i mean and some dudes are
gee about it they won't tell you they'll
just get off on you
and i respect that because i mean
there's part of me that dwells within
that too even i don't want any of it
anymore that's where i was set for like
the first
35 years of my life it came to that
point and then i realized i was like
this is a [ __ ] joke man
there's no camaraderie there's no
there's no togetherness there's no unity
there's no we got you dog don't worry
about it and there's trust no [ __ ] no
it's a den of thieves it's like falling
asleep in a black widow's nest
you're just never gonna wake up
you know
it's been like
a spell of hopelessness man like a real
dark cave
and it's changing [ __ ]
in ways that i don't
i'm not i'm not really cool with
you know like i'm not a danger to nobody
else unless you try me like you really
come pursue my life
then i mean
we're gonna see i mean it's just what it
is i don't wanna i don't wanna put out
there i'm not a tough guy i'm just me
and i don't wanna be tough and i'm not
bad i'm like gang member i'm not nothing
but
i want to be around for my kids man
the ones that are still here
and
that's all i want so i ever wanted was
my family
just kind of sucks it
[ __ ] never had it
had an inkling of it for a second and it
was taken
and then
i was made to feel like it was my fault
you know like
yeah dude i [ __ ] up and i [ __ ] was
down kicking with my homeboy working on
his car with him
and we were drinking
and i had both of them in a stroller
little side-by-side stroller
and i remember like being like eight
blocks from the house and it's in like
upland
rancho area
and it started raining
and so i started running
pushing the stroller
and i [ __ ] didn't see a crack in the
sidewalk there was like a
and it flipped and it flipped over the
top and i ended over the top of
and
i thought that it was because of that
but that had happened
and they they didn't even believe me
that i did that
they thought that i'd like i don't know
grab her and [ __ ] smash their head off
the wall or some [ __ ]
and i couldn't believe they were [ __ ]
saying that i was like stunned like what
the what the [ __ ] are you serious
and no matter what i said
and my story was always that
always
not because i'm lying about it because
that's the [ __ ] truth
that's all i knew was that
they're telling me there's other
injuries they're like wow how how i mean
i started looking it up and i see that
like any time an infant's given chest
compressions
ribs break
or anything like that and i'm like
thinking i didn't give them that maybe
the doctors did because i had to take
them they were premature
her mom was spun out
they were premature by like two months
so when they were born they were on
apnea motors
they were on breathers in the nicu
because their lungs weren't fully formed
yet that's like the last thing that
forms is the lungs because they don't
need them in mom's belly
i went through all these all these
details and i i started seeing there was
something wrong
and and by the time like it came time
for sentencing
by the time they gave me the first deal
wasn't a life top and i was like what
the [ __ ] why would they do that you know
like
if
you really think that i did that then
why wouldn't you just max me on
because
i would understand that
and that would be expected and anything
else that came from that would be
expected so i understand that part of it
too like all of it all of it
it's an ugly thing and
to have to stare at
that
which has
mortally wounded your soul and
everything that you thought you were
and left you in this heap of
ashes
becomes like
an untruth
because it's an archaic experience that
nobody else can understand
unless they've walked through it and i
wouldn't wish that on anybody
nobody
and yet
i walk through it every day
and yeah i'd like i'd love to lay it
over here
just do a big ass shot and i'm asleep
but
that would hurt the rest of my the other
two kids so
i'm stuck here
you know trying to be a better man
a better human being
and just
a person
and
i don't know if the world's gonna let me
do that
all right crash thank you so much for
sharing your story that's so good i wish
you the best of luck from here
thank you thank you
you